I agree you don't look like you take
stories at all he's not big enough he's
definitely not big enough no his nipples
are too small way too small tiny nipples
his nipples are too strong we're gonna
take steroids at least look bigger
[Music]
I'm gonna start this one off with
another photo oh yeah yay no spoilers
what happened talk about it talk about
it oh those are acne scars huh no way
that's like Gucci that looks like
something else are those acne scars or
no that looks like uh my boy Dark Age
syphilis what do you think it is oh man
what's that term where you're like over
scar it looks like
um blisters there's like some people
they can't get tattoos because like
let's say if they get a cut the skin
grows back like on the outside crazy
yeah like keloids keloids
it looks pain I've never known about
this is that a uh what do you call it
like a side effect from steroids this is
a side effect from no way there's a
bodybuilder who's showing off the
serious damages steroids have done to
his body in a bid to warn others oh you
just never know what happens to you
right it's random because of how
hormones will react to each individual
huh oh so it's by the person everyone
has different receptors and so you don't
it's really hard to predict how you will
take things and also when you're not
doing it in a regimented way like a lot
of bodybuilders it's just let's just go
[__] ham yeah so instead of treating
it like a scientific experiment like the
way you should a lot of people are just
self-diagnosing self-dosing and then
they just like the effects are crazy
it's so ironic though because you like
want to work out so you look good with
your shirt off and like lighting
conditions are high and then you know
you want to turn the lights off
it's like oh geez so yeah you're right
these are called keloid scars very very
good wow
um a keloid scar is an enlarged raised
scar that can be pink red skin colored
or darker than the surrounding skin this
is a bodybuilder from Ireland who's
super like you know got into it got
super obsessed with it really enjoyed
you know training with this other
bodybuilder that's how he got into the
sport and whatnot
and he said you know when you go to the
gym and start making progress people
accuse you of taking steroids as
bodybuilder and bodybuilding is a short
career so he's like [__] it I decided to
just go for it take some stuff
who might as well do it what did I think
I'm gonna do that anyways I'm gonna
[__] just do it anyway when bar would
come to the gym that I used to work at
all the time people were like yo that
guy's on the steroids right like this
dude's for sure on steroids and I go no
I really don't think Bart's on Sarah is
he's just a strong buff guy I'm not even
show the guns dude I'm not even close to
like yeah but you can steroids but you
hang out with a bunch of like freaks
though oh yeah like a bunch of like
genetic freaks like normal people you're
on Star Wars I agree you don't look like
you take stories at all he's not big
enough man he's definitely not big
enough no dude his nipples are too small
way too small tiny nipples his nipples
are too small we're gonna take steroids
at least look bigger
I did wonderful like half a second was
big enough to be like no I don't think
so let's do squatting 400 pounds in the
early all right so like remember like
before Instagram and how Fitness got so
popular right like going to the gym was
a really not everyone's like normal
thing to do now it's like pretty average
at least someone dabbled in it so during
that time we had a buddy he was skinny
as [__] right and he kept telling me yo
man we gotta we gotta intervene with
Bart and I'm like why and he's all like
man I've seen this before like guys that
get in the bodybuilding like they're
he's all into steroids I know it I know
it and I'm all like I've lived with him
for days there's not been a moment I
would have with them for minutes many
days I see him taking his medicine with
a needle every day I know he's not on
steroids that's insulin that's for
diabetes [__] how would you know like
how are you so sure and he was so
[__] sure that Bart was on steroids
and we needed to have an intervention
dude this always happens some one person
goes through something and now they need
to copy paste that to everybody yeah
it's so annoying and and this guy was so
skinny he looked like skeletons with
skin oh yeah he did skeletons
Laurel he's so scared of steroids he
went the egg all the way yeah
he's like don't lift weights dude it
[__] you up it kills you dude women go
through that [__] too when they get too
skinny and like people start going oh
she must be like depressed or on drugs
or some [__] yeah dude look at poor
Rebel Wilson dude chick loses some
weight and she's getting more hate than
ever yeah dude and Adele Adele's getting
hella hate hello sucks now she's fat
phobic for being [__] that's what
they do they're like she's fat phobic
because she's like taking pictures of
herself like wearing nice clothes even
even lizzo who didn't lose weight said
she was like eating healthier and
everyone started cheating on her for
that yeah
like I'm not even losing weight I'm just
eating better yeah I'm just eating more
vegetables dude get off my back just for
her [__] life span I can't believe
people are pissed at lizzo about that
and not the crystal flute thing
no one's talking about it oh it's a
twofer it's a twofer piss me off like
nothing else it is it is sometimes more
entertaining when somebody was
entertaining when they're big oh like
Jonah Hill when they gave him [__] yeah
for sure yeah it helps yeah yeah yeah
yeah I agree I agree that's very true
I'm not trying to do a [__] because you
know we're on a live stream or anything
it is hard for like you know like the
Matt Rife how he like a lot of his
comedies a stand-up comedian that's
objectively [__] hot and a lot of his
material is about being hot and it's so
[__] funny but if he just didn't
address it and tried to be funny
normally it would be pretty hard yeah a
lot of people would just not laugh at
him imagine skinny Chris Farley yeah
that is good imagine skinny Point like
this yeah no Beverly Hills ninjas yeah
see guys they want to keep their guys
fat not because they're like you're
being fat phobic but because you're not
funny anymore yeah we missed the Jiggles
that's true imagine this is funny
imagine a six foot Danny DeVito yeah not
as good is that weird yeah that is weird
he has to be fat it feels like a
Gallagher
all stretched out yeah look what
Gallagher had to do man you gotta smash
[__] watermelons does this guy have
like a surgeon general's warning or
something he wants to tell the world
well at the end of the day I think uh
like you said uh people are self-dosing
and doing all these dumbass stuff this
guy said I got mine off a guy in my gym
which I wouldn't recommend doing
whatsoever because you could be taking
anything you got to hit up liver King's
guide a lot of those guys what would
what would be the right way to get they
start slow so the right way and if we
could get Dr Mike here one day he'll
tell you the super right way because he
actually has a PHD in [__]
Kinesiology and stuff but uh the super
right way so before you get into like
full-blown anabolic steroids which is
what I want let's all do it what people
are doing now I guess the legal way is
hormone replacement therapy you guys
familiar with that so like trt yeah yeah
so it's like it's uh like my test levels
aren't high enough so let's get get it
back to maybe normal range and then
maybe a little bit better so maybe back
when I was 25 or maybe even better so
usually the symptoms of low test is like
you're depressed low ambition you can't
sleep that well maybe you don't have
morning wood or whatever or your sex
drives low so you have actual symptoms
that you're trying to treat versus the
um bodybuilders they're just taking
arbitrary amounts a thousand milligrams
of this and it's like well what are you
trying to treat I don't know it's got to
be a thousand milligrams versus the
other way you have symptoms you're
trying to treat and you give the lowest
dosage possible of one specific steroid
and you bump it up and then you wait
like two weeks do you feel better you is
your sex drive up do you feel less
depressed and then they slowly bump it
up there and then then they start adding
things to your like a cocktail or
whatever they call it and they'll start
adding other things to fix those
symptoms and the minute those are fixed
you're good it's like literally like
taking like antibiotics right like once
you don't have the flu-like symptoms you
feel good you don't [__] heal from
your colds from antibiotics and I'm
gonna take another three things of
penicillin just for the [__] of it
because that starts going into this
realm and so that's kind of like the
very very clear difference but now
um in the bodybuilding world people are
approaching it from a more science and
more like medical based way so it is
getting I guess smarter and like there's
a ton of phds that are on steroids now
because they just enjoy the hobby of
getting jacked so there are like uh like
proper ways of doing it now is that is
that how the Russians did it yeah so
those guys they have actual Chemists in
their like national teams that are
administering this so those guys have
been doing it like the correct way and
they're doing it in a way where how can
I get these athletes on and also get
away with the piss test so it's like
full circle versus these guys they don't
give a [__] but yeah test me anytime I'm
a fail every single time no matter what
yeah cause I'm on everything you know
still couldn't be Rocky though
this guy talks about how he had two
severe breakouts of acne and boils uh he
had one more after he stopped taking the
drugs so uh quote I ended up having my
first breakout on my back Midway through
2020 and this is when I was uh when I
lowered the amount I was taken a lot of
people have said to me why uh didn't I
stop after the first boil but I was
working towards a bodybuilding show
which she had already put years of hard
work into fries are nuts too really what
fries stopping taking it well the minute
you take exogenous hormones meaning
hormones outside of your body it tells
your body to stop producing its own and
if you take it for a long enough period
of time like people that are on actual
steroids once they come off uh they'll
start getting like gyno because they
start building like because it's like a
reverse effect so you have too high up
estrogen so they'll start getting like
girl tits and stuff and they have to be
on trt for the rest of their life they
have to be boy yeah Bart knows a lot
about steroids
I really want to be honest maybe we need
an intervention this is what this is
this is an intervention yeah I saw a guy
in Hawaii that was balding but had
titties in a Hello Kitty backpack I was
wondering maybe he used to take steroids
you could always tell though it's always
a Hello Kitty backpack I saw a chick at
the airport and she was wearing a
t-shirt that says I woke up like this
but then she ironically looked like she
woke up like two seconds ago and I was
like does she know yeah yeah am I gonna
tell her like should I just be like hey
you look like [__] you look like you
just woke up you just woke up like is
this supposed to be ironic yeah good if
it is that's great I was troubled by it
yeah she like she's supposed to be like
oh can you believe it I'm so pretty but
I woke up like this
bro like actually no you look like you
just did yeah but isn't that what they
do like you're you're supposed to be hot
in your that shirt and then everyone's
like oh badge Queen oh my God
I'm a little [__] Queen oh my God
Slayer supposed to say that oh yeah you
should have told her next time make sure
you go up to her I was so troubled by it
I went in this in that Subway thing that
they take you to the house just like
this for a while like yeah the little
transport I should have said something I
had a Larry David moment I was like what
do I do yeah you should win you know
what you did
you did it you sure did man [__] did
it
steroids huh I'm thinking about it
steroids think about it every day man
but once Dr Mike talked about it and he
was saying like Tesla made me not want
to do yeah oh the depressive stuff like
you just kind of feeling like really
anxious all the time feeling like
someone's gonna kill you out of nowhere
when you're just taking a shower so Dr
Mike is bigger Pro bodybuilder as in he
took steroids yes yeah and he opened
about it he's so super open about it and
he was like you know he does his
injections uh twice a week won this in
the beginning once uh in the uh in the
end of the week and it's a hormonal
cycle it's literally giving yourself a
period like uh like a man period right
so he was like there's times where it's
like he takes it [__] crazy test it
out I'll [__] kill anybody and then
Thursday he sees mountains like oh my
God the [__] mouth I'm so [__]
beautiful
because the test comes down your
estrogen goes up like a [__] and
so when I hear [__] like that I'm like
dude I don't know if I could handle this
kind of like bipolar transparent about
it I'm a normal person dude imagine just
going through your normal life when I'm
driving by myself I called someone a
[__] stupid [__] today and I was
like right after I said it I was like I
gotta relax dude and then you go
sometimes I'm taking a shower and I have
a panic attack yeah oh God [__] oh [__]
what the [__] happened I'm like I don't
know about all that dude
I'll have what he's having yeah yeah
yeah that sounds like being a woman
that's a video
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]